i'm christopher lloyd here talking with
gq about
some of my
iconic characters
[Music]
back to the future
i got the script read the script
and i discarded it something you don't
usually do
and a friend of mine who is there said
you know
i never did that when i was in new york
no matter how remote the possibility
that i might be cast
i'd show up so i thought yeah
she's right so
i got it all the way straight for a
basket
and i went back and met bob's a back ass
and it all
came true
[Music]
he was always like
one
second away from a crisis
and the whole
universe as we know it will collapse if
you mess up the time space continuum so
there's that pressure and also i i used
to read about scientists like einstein
einstein biography and
a couple of others people get so
involved
you know in something
and then
they're getting on a bus
and
big no
e equals mc squared
you know
and i felt
the doc had a lot they that was the day
i invented time travel
i remember it vividly i was standing on
the edge of my toilet hanging a clock
the porcelain was wet i slipped hit my
head on the edge of the sink and when i
came to i had a revelation a vision a
picture in my head a picture of this
this is what makes time travel possible
the flux capacitor well i usually
try to stay in character you know
without being a pastor
but just to hold on to it i remember one
time
when i was
starting out filming i had
a fairly tricky scene for me at the time
it was a master shot
and finally they got it what they wanted
and i
i
felt great i went to craft services
and then they said well now we're gonna
do the close-ups
and i was like oh my god because i was
done already
you know i didn't i didn't think about
it so
i just try to stay
focused
whether i'm in my sitting in my trailer
wait
or whatever because i want to be there
when the moment comes
[Music]
[Music]
i did not
do that
i did not do that for about four flights
that's a stunt guy did that he did a
stunt once on the statue of liberty
where he was hold a flagpole up on top
and the flagpole be released and bend
down to some ledge or whatever and he'd
drop off
and he did that you know i was
crazy and he said the only thing he was
afraid of is that the pole would snap
otherwise everything's
hey doc we better back up we don't have
enough roads to get up to 88 roads
well we're going we don't need
roads there was another actor
and
michael came in after we shot for six
weeks they just decided
that they needed somebody with a comic
flair you know
and still wonderful actor i had no idea
there's a change coming one night we
were shooting in the
mall
beginning sequence we were asked to come
to one of the trailers
at one o'clock in the morning
and
spielberg was there and
he made the announcement
of a change my biggest
fear was that
because i was really working
to get doc right
i was the starter
i thought i don't know if i could get it
up to do that again so i was worried
about it but all worked out michael
we had a
chemistry which
lasted
the whole time we could come back after
a break and just be there you know you
didn't have to work for it so that that
was great
your future is whatever you make it so
make it a good one
both of you
we will doc
stand
you know three or four or five years
it sank in that this dust doesn't stop
i mean the kids who saw it when the film
first came out
grew up and had kids who they began
their lives with it and so many people
have come up to me and saying how i made
their childhood or the phil made their
childhood
or they became engineers or
scientists or surgeons or whatever
from
the effect of the film movement and
nothing else i've done has had that kind
of impact
boy
i knew
a little bit you know i hadn't been
watching but i've
seen the characters i thought it was
kind of fun you know kind of cool i just
thought it'd be great to see the world
of
rick and morty
and dr marty somehow collide
out in some
galactic
hundreds of millions of miles away
and suddenly what that could be fun
one flew over the cuckoo's nest
i went to new york right out of
high school and i was in new york until
cuckoo's nest
until after it opened and i just got to
a point where i felt
some actors don't make the transition
from theater
to film
and that maybe because i went out i went
up for films i'd be set up
nothing and then they came to new york
to cast one play over the cougars that i
was submitted
auditioned i may have auditioned twice
i'm not sure and then
that's
that they're coming
up some kind of morbid [ __ ] or
something
[ __ ] feel peculiar you've been
talking about your wife ever since i can
remember you know she's on your mind and
blah blah blah blah it was great because
i i think most of us were there about
two weeks before
we started shooting and we go to the
various
areas of a facility people in for
different
levels of emotional problems and
we sat in on meetings actually like the
ones in the film
so it was great it was really
helpful it was said that
over time we were there for 12 weeks
many of the staff so
some of the cast needed to be
institutionalized
come on come on come on i can be pushed
just so far see what are you doing you
touch me once
just touch me once more just once more
huh just once more
just touch me once again
so they had to completely shift the
schedule around but i remember when we
picked up the scene again after he came
back which was about maybe three weeks
later or whatever i couldn't get into
the groove i couldn't get back there i
couldn't find my way back into the scene
and i was aware of it
nixon
kind of
came over to me just you know nonsense
it was
and he said something to me
that put me right back there right back
in the scene i was like
saved
[Music]
i was in boston after clue was us to
open i was by myself i
had dinner and this group of they're all
scottish the kilts the whole deal
bagpipes about four or five of them
going by and coming by another way i
mean they were just
slowly going all over the place late at
night like one-ish in the morning one of
them
comes down
still in his gear
with uh playing the bagpipe and i just
stopped to watch him
go back because it was
kind of surreal suddenly he looked at me
said i know you
you were in one full of the cook's nest
[Music]
taxi
including seth came out and
you know i got
uh an agent
beverly hills
i was still living in new york i just
packed up and came out
and i had lunch with
the guy and
i was asked to sign but i
didn't want to do any
sick hop
i had a kind of a
attitude acquired in new york growing up
there and everything
doing a sitcom you know what do you want
to do that [ __ ] for my new age would
send me up to
meet other people at other sitcoms and
he would say just you know go up meeting
me over and over down the road
yeah
i said okay
then i went from taxi and then
ruined my life
well boss
i'm back from my vacation
you didn't have to run into your brains
while you were out there did you
no but i wasn't really looking
what i remember most about every once in
a while on a friday because we do the
show friday night and there'll be a live
audience and
we
have complete run-through costumes
everybody would be there riders you know
you know now we gotta break for dinner
and get back time but there'd be
something that needed a solution
some not working and how and so we
frantically work on that scene
and so he worked on that scene you know
to come up with the tag or the scene the
right
line and they and i would say i was
still very new to this process so i'm
just like
i'm in the fishbowl and so they you know
they'd say try this so we'd do the scene
didn't work try that and somebody
came up with that
i don't think it was a writer i was
somebody up in the
ropes or somewhere i didn't if somebody
came up with that
they'd know it worked
what does a yellow light mean
slow down
okay
what
yellow
light paint
slow down okay
what was that like working with tom
hanks we didn't have any
direct like conversation
but we were bouncing around as i
remember kind of a
in somebody's room at harvard being
[ __ ] don't you understand huh i mean
all the studying
all the books
in all the libraries
and all the gymnasiums
i forgot my thoughts
he was early on
in his career but i remember somebody
saying that that's
time i think
i don't know i didn't know that yet
[Music]
star trek three the search for spark
kaplan
[Music]
it was kind of a trip they actually had
a book a dictionary of clung and ease
it was about that thick with all the
word meanings pronunciation use in a
sentence like a regular webster's a
failure
the most powerful destructive force ever
created
you
will tell me the secret
of the genesis torpedo
i have no knowledge
that i hope pain is something you enjoy
how do you feel you've been able to get
into the mind of these more villainous
characters
well i'm maybe i'm a repressed criminal
and it's just an outlet
i i know i enjoy it
give me what i want and i'll consider it
you fool look around you
the planet's destroying itself yes
exhilarating isn't it i mean
captain kirk
with that
stuff i was wearing and the look of the
face and i have a struggle with a huge
worm
a lot i mean
that's kind of fun
the tender bar
well i got a call
saying
that i was being offered this role and i
got the script and
read the script
i found my grandpa
i felt i could do something with that i
liked the character so i was very
excited you all end up back here you are
a stingy crazy old bastard you are not
stingy with money i've got any you are
stingy
with love oh i didn't do that girls
become wives and mothers that was his
point of view you became one of them oh
shut up you old turd ah they bought this
house
he does nothing to improve it or take
care of it
i has a family none of whom seem to be
able to make enough money to have their
own house
so they're all in there and it's not
what he wants he wants to
them to do as well as they can or under
the circumstances and i just feel he
feels a lot
he feels for them whether it's the kid
or
or his wife or
brother whoever he feels well
but it's a it's
hell
a lot of the time
it's from a woman who learns 30 bucks a
day and after college
at harvard or yale you are going to law
school so you can sue your father for
childhood no so he can help you with
your fines about the septic tank
i like
you know how
[Music]
diverse
grandpa is farting away
i haven't seen one of those robbed
so i feel like broke new ground and i
love that about him and in the in the
novel there's
some little
pieces about him that aren't in the film
simply you know because i couldn't put
everything in there but yeah he's a
piece of work
our educational system and indeed our
society as a whole
was destroyed in the 19th century by the
german influence really ability has a
concept turned into a mechanical
empirical construct
but he really does
love the kid
i really see his potential there and
he tells the kid if you know your mom's
got
something there
it's gonna be taken out
be nice to you mom you know he's like
he's got a heart regardless
of the system in place
he's the likeliest to be able to leave
my house
on his own abilities
it's like
working with a team you know they just
all of them are so wonderful so talented
and so committed
all of us to
george that was one wonderful i mean
you do your work come in prepared and he
just
brings it out there's a lot of heart
from everybody which i think
makes the film
so good